[ __ ] all right and we are live welcome
to the Isle of podcast and the Lords of
gaming dotnet episode number 108 and
it's another glorious Sunday we're back
at the roundtable on the Lord's Day I'm
very excited about our special guest and
we've got Mortal Kombat 11 days gone III
and scarlet rumors and Disney Gaming
acquisitions to discuss so we gonna get
right into it
I want to introduce the Lord whom Lord
cake and I had the absolute pleasure to
meet at PAX East 2019 now under this
Lord represent one third of the most
entertaining journalists in the game
with dr. Bob and crispy but they're
hilarious takes our gaming drinking and
pop-culture easily make them the life of
any party you're still retaining a
passion of hardcore gamers everywhere
introducing the host of not another
gaming podcast and the co-founder of
wicked good gaming calm the life of the
gaming after-party and everyone's
favorite professional degenerate love
from detail in making his debut into the
realm of the Lords mommy Lord papadum
are you doing sir
oh man Jesus they're having a brown baby
I am bright
lutely and you told me you were gonna
lace me up with that intro and holy hell
you did I'm gonna try to keep the only
with a PFG swears that you can say ah I
got about early and we have to make sure
that I have all of the merchandise very
heavily represented yeah we gonna have
to make myself feel at home pull up a
chair you know put the slide right now
it looks like I'm broadcasting live from
a cratenbarrel back
I just held bridal shower yesterday for
me and my future wife so we've got to
the right yeah thank you thank you long
overdue we will talk about this day for
a minute Matthew brothers out there
tremendous time salute to the team to
man salute to the team Chris my boy yeah
yeah Patriot guys getting a jet patriot
rivalry on don't know about this do
right but I'll tell you something so
main cog me those over there and he's
like cognate he's like you ever dog to
you reading comic books right you find
out like bizarro world
he's so black him so they kickin it
right homie he didn't have black yo dude
just got infatuated with each other
ourselves because we're talking he is
the same and he's a patriot fan the way
I'm a jet fan this is crazy right we my
supposed to talk this was the oil and
water right here facts not at all for at
least two hours basically but listen
listen yo it gets even more bizarre they
have a doppelganger
just like sovereign yeah our crispy was
going over do you our Lord in your realm
it's only right we show you the proper
respect here at the round table where
have you been playing service but going
on shoot man
man listen I have been really really
sinking my teeth into the division to I
told myself that I was not gonna rush
out and get it I was like man I'm not
gonna I don't know I don't know if I'm
gonna
like every time a shared world shooter I
know you guys are big destiny guys every
time a game like that comes out I
figured and I think I told you guys at
PAX 2 I was like I'm gonna wait because
I'm gonna wait for like division to the
taken King to come out and be totally
remastered and inevitably fixed whatever
they messed up but I heard non-stop
great things you know I had so many
buddies that were playing it and got
onto it so I've been playing the
division 2 non-stop and yeah that's just
been pretty much my jam lately and also
just keeping up with Skyrim right now so
I mean for the Nintendo see ya only at
least we know they both like watching
powerpoints oh that's good good to hear
laughs we won't get into this stuff and
of course you know we got the Four
Horsemen of gaming those original Lords
of the realm here at the roundtable my
calls were the Col most my brother from
another mother the difficult game
Conqueror and the half of the young wolf
mommy
Lord addicts are you doing sir doing
pretty good I finally beat that record I
sighs finally
hey my little brother the last boss is
literally gonna drive me insane install
it brother no rank where does he rank in
terms of difficulty for you Oh hardest
boss I've ever fought wow wow wow yeah
yeah you know I will never fight him now
is it is it cheap difficult or just
difficult it's fair it's just it's long
and enduring
like he has four phases it's a war of
attrition it's like an in-game type of
game take a break right you needed an
intermission right boy if I even that
you have to take a break you can easily
mess up because you have to fight him so
long
hmm so yeah you know you have to fight
him for 4 health bars that's a lot of
times there's ice we're about an hour
and a half to 2 each news about to get
cursed out right there you just about to
get cursed out but you did it and I
salute you sir
that's something I will never do we
comfortable we comfortable with
ourselves a whole second all week for
you pretty much I have to I'm gonna I
started the review it's gonna take me a
little bit mm-hm ah but you know it was
a good game I do think that I don't
think it's the best game they've ever
made well okay it's definitely a good
game every right now he's recovering
from his wounds right now in post-op
PTSD now and of course we have our most
technical gaming Lord the solo gamer who
lives for the single player selfish
experience and also that's Astrid honest
mr. off my profile Illuminati and lore
patreon of the iron bank mom made Lord
sovereign how you doing sir I'm chillin
man I got back yesterday whoa I got back
yesterday and I was like first of all I
had to drink like a gallon of water I
was like all right let me get me get
rehydrated yeah and then I proceeded to
download the best looking bootleg I can
find just to watch are you talking about
crazy I mean I got insist that King
David read that
can lie in games is a seven out of ten
for most most for me too much of the GU
speech for most of the part I did
appreciate them showing psychological
impacts of the snaps that's what i'ma
talk about it when it gets a mouthwash I
don't know why we all jump in solvent
section we always do around everybody I
don't care yeah so I picked up m'kay I
wasn't gonna I was gonna wait and then I
said you know what let me just pick it
up so I picked it up on PC I did on PC I
was not I was not King you gotta chill
with that you got you've got I can't
would you continue so and then I said
that I'll play a little bit of it just a
story most or most things pretty cool
game runs beautifully on the PC I've had
any issues um and then what the heck
else did I pick up oh yeah so I did pick
up days gone I played a couple of hours
oh you know I was gonna do that because
I was gonna when I get to my segment
I'll tell you what what happened so I
picked up I can't I haven't played
enough to really assess anything other
than the game is beautiful
no but that's it I'll be for as far as
what you've been playing that's pretty
much it no doubt no doubt and of course
you know we got the Incredible Hulk of
this aka the XS gamer oh the lord of
combat sports
the king of statutes who demands nothing
less than that premium experience it is
the leader of the fraud alert movement
Oh beloved Lord King how you doing sir
I'm doing fantastic I'm doing extra
fantastic now that we got all wiki
gaming in here this is this is what I'm
talking about I am so happy that he came
through I knew this was it you don't
match meet in heaven it was luck I'm
missing my man Bob - I'm really not
feeling Bob now
but I want you to understand he is so
lit y'all will love him y'all got to
definitely go with my channel and
definitely watch listen subscribe
mommy see panels right there twisting
right back there twisting it a lot of
stuff happened where he's I an analyst
is I um I'm getting my infinite bloody
knuckles if you're in a check and you
please come to the front of the
congregation sir wait attic you gotta I
want you to understand a couple of
things first this week I was playing I
was playing hell-blade this week I was
playing a division to ouray know what it
is me hot monkey love inside nice man
actually tearing it out but hell-blade
if you've never played it and it's in
game past right now mmm-hmm and you know
I put game pass up there like the best
thing since sliced bread
um it is probably the weirdest
psychological thriller mm-hmm that you
can ever listen to put your headsets on
when you play it please do not play it
but just surround so I know how hot your
surround sound is I know how you gotta
do that yeah with a headset bro Atmos Oh
bro it's things that go on in there that
is necessary for a headset and I can
play yeah me and addict talked about it
and he said that you know a lot of stuff
was going on that he only played a half
an hour of it he couldn't take it no
more yeah it is mentally it is such a
great use of sound that it mentally
messes with you actually the PlayStation
5 is a
Xbox X right now so if you boot up
hell-blade you can get the fixation five
experience Nate yo diz going in he said
King they he the King gonna make you go
broker joining the statute movement but
then he says kid can't ask the knees he
old saw my house and when I turn it on
and I go to put in my disc and it's a
pay five dollars URL is gonna be so
crazy you're just like put your knees up
dizzy finna knee gauntlet needs to be
hey what's up brothers good know I'm a
great a veggies we kid yes yes yes so
that's what you've been rocking the Noel
blaze situation it's been hell blade we
have some wack fights last night shout
out know what I'm not even to talk about
him because he disappointed me so bad
that's why combat talk because I knew
the disappointment we have the Lord the
cooperative experience in gaming name
engine himself the shinobi lore Cognito
spreading everyone is in the room and I
LP now telling you what you want to hear
but you need to hear avengers endgame we
already know what that went down
shoutout to the roundtable reviews with
Laura Chi and Lord saw that is up on ILP
channel all the spoilery stuff is in
there so go check that out your recipes
Cassidy - hustler it was a good run oh
sorry bro we got 300 like crazy when
they got to the [ __ ] talk I want you
to listen this is not when you hear me
what I'm saying and you might say old
Kings out here doing wicked bashing when
you get to that part doing it crowd
wanted what good gave them yes and goods
wash cassidy in a
fashion that Cassidy with you know we
got this thing right when we be for each
other
shout out the kid when we stop beefing
it's good we saw snapping and then I
start really getting good on Ken
yeah then he's gone to realize well you
know real life thought eBay just the
boss is outdated bro so yes salute to
cast you know it was a good run you know
back in the day and a cipher but on that
big stage brother wasn't was the
translation at the black magic last
night he had me rolling we called me on
the phone we talked about it you know
saying but that was dead and then um
yeah other than that it was on there was
a fight song did you catch a Shaka day
and when I missed it I started watching
because I think that the the early
premiums on ESPN and I had it on I
wasn't paying much attention um but I
didn't get to the jackal refight I don't
yeah it was good it was good it's just
one of those situations where just like
you know great fight
you know jackal just trying to one punch
and he's working on the body but this
young boy he's number ten right I'm I
forget his name right now but um yeah he
did he really good man great Jets had a
great combination kept pressure kept
apace really good fight and I think the
other boy on one football player what's
his name Hardy he was in there he won
and um that was a hold on say I think so
straight off is my history they muted it
so he jumped out the bushes but anyway
so so hopefully solvent come back but
yeah that was that as far as gaming um
he has been a Mortal Kombat 11 all day
we'll get into that yeah I pay you now
you back you back um was gonna say as
far as arm
yo days going I got game stop man I got
a beef job and like they got this
promotion where you do the physical um I
believe it's like 48 hours you admit it
from purchase so I'm like alright I'll
pick it up and um what ends up happening
is you're not going in I'm like yeah I'm
ready
you know get my physical get my 48 hours
of play days gonna let's go
today is like yeah so um I don't know
what made me ask us like your soul is it
from the data purchase right and then 48
hours and then I get a chance to blaze
out
return if I want I thought the promotion
was really cool so he was a whole let me
check my manager so the guy goes to the
back and then he's like um yeah it's um
actually from the deed actually came out
now from the date when you purchase so I
pick it up on a Saturday you kindly have
to return it tomorrow only applies from
so if you pick it up the following week
none of those things apply shut out the
game start with the film get a bunch of
people that don't ask yeah that's the
thing like they're expecting you or day
launch day right to beat it so if you
miss launch day you're 48 hour clock has
already started that's what it is I'm
like oh no actually that was actually
one of my first jobs I was running I was
running the finesse you know what I
games tapas is like a big toy store
right now and ever since I got my
Nintendo switch console I've been on the
like digital wave you know regular show
just for them yeah yeah yeah that's fact
that's a fact lock me in but ya know I
mean I've been doing the whole digital
thing ever since I got the switch that
was kind of my test my test run and then
every time I have to go into a game stop
I was I'm like oh god Wow why is it such
a like you know and I know that you know
everybody goes in there for different
reasons I mean you might want games you
might want status you might just want to
like you might want to go in there and
have some sort of like intelligent
conversation with somebody who if you
got like I mean you know I have like a
favorite doughnuts employee who knows my
coffee order uh which is not easy
because it was not hard because it's
just a large black cold brew every
single time it's not hard but like you
know if you go in there to see a
specific person you know yeah a
relationship yeah yeah and that's cool
but like gamestop I know I mean I
haven't been on the other side of the
counter I know it's tough for them too
because of the way they have to do the
head they have to push things and I mean
this those doors were a mess man every
time I go into a game stuff there's
stuff all over the floors it looks like
somebody just knocked over a rack of
Funko pops
kids and yeah I just I try to avoid it I
the last time I bought a physical game
was Red Dead Redemption - and I went to
a Best Buy I was in and out in two
seconds and that was pretty much all I
needed
yeah hey man I think I'm in the same
boat as you lower down because um it's
like he says if it's not for that
favorite employee that you have their
relation with I went completely digital
you know means so even the whole like
you know the whole thing about a
midnight release there's no need because
I'm doing everything from the
convenience of my home so it's just like
yeah it's interesting cuz they're gonna
have to definitely go to a transition
but I thought the promotion I was like
oh this is a cool way to get people to
get physical cuz I'm like oh they let
you rock 48 hours and then you can bring
it back and get full credit and do what
you want
after you blaze it and especially for
single-player games I'm like oh that's
my face oh my new finesse I didn't even
know that they could do that
yes I've never seen this promotion it
was strictly four days going shout out
to the cops is goombah but oh they're
strictly for all days going and it was
like hey if you purchase you know I'm
saying you have 48 hours to play it do
what you want returning you know I'm
saying and um you know then at that
point you get full credit for the game
so yeah you know it's a shame just
wished it was hell because he was
planning his finesse you know my money
and I'm gonna go we up and do something
else I was like I was in here like that
don't sound like the GameStop I know the
funny part about it is that sounds
exactly like that PlayStation when y'all
go slander anyway I'm reading up on it
now and that is that's pretty crazy with
the returns within two days of release
yeah he's gone the only eligible game
for now but you know and that's kind of
like I mean I guess four days gone I
don't know how long the game is I just I
haven't read many great things about it
but I didn't see anything about the
longevity one way or the other and I
mean for your games that I mean I don't
know
uncharted 4 I didn't get a chance to
play yet but you know I don't know if
that games any longer than 12 hours for
its main story or anything like that
yeah earn through that hmm it's a nice
sixty three dollars and 74 cents with
Massachusetts state tax anyway that you
don't have to spend which is nice which
you were on which you man yeah so that's
pretty much been in for me so now that
the Lord's gotten into what they've been
playing I want to start briefly I don't
have a lot of time but we got to do a
little history with Lord Dom mmm video
game system history what led him to
create another gaming podcast and his
journey as our favorite journalist Oh
wicked gaming calm which a good gaming
calm so no I dog this stuff from the
beginning man what's some of the first
video game system yeah we got you man so
I grew up with so thank you and I grew
up with Super Nintendo I was always the
Nintendo kid in school people are
talking about grand theft auto mics man
you guys don't have that Luigi's Mansion
playing with me I don't need reyes san
andreas come on yeah you want to talk
about an open-world game let's talk
about Delfino Plaza and Super Mario
Sunshine they don't know about that life
though you don't know about that at all
that's no I definitely know about that
was coming around on yeah so I was a you
know goat and I would walk over to my
buddies I was growing up you play like
ps2 if I wanted to kind of get some
experience as a man the evospeed
underground this game is dope and you
know but uh ya know I grew up with
Nintendo stuff I mean I had a Sega
Genesis in the Super Nintendo
you know it was a my you know game boys
all that so I always had Nintendo I
think I've only ever missed the Wii U
was the only nintendo console i haven't
always know I mean it smart man good boy
yeah yep yep and I was just like I don't
think there's anything for the Wii U and
I was like smash is coming oh it's
coming for the dsr I'll grab for the DS
um but ya know I've always been a big
Nintendo guy Xbox is my main like now
current-gen
platform so I had the fingers please
yeah so yeah I mean I had the original
Xbox the 360 the you know all that cuz I
was like damn I got like a game
cube broadband adapter I'm gonna need
something I can actually play online
games cuz Halo 2 came out and that was a
game changer for me so yeah and so
mainly I mean I'm a big RPG guy I kind
of have a little common bond with
sovereign with you know playing the
single-player stuff playing the RPGs in
them you know drop 4000 hours into this
don't talk to anybody for a week
yeah yeah yeah so I've been known to
like drop off the face of the earth for
a little while when I when I get into it
what's the Fred Fred Lee bender he's
going in on you he said Xbox I can't
take you serious itty more oh man you
started with that man I like that after
I have to get a whole
I need like a nice comprehensive
easy-to-use user interface and every
time I like the ps3 killed it for me I
was like I can't blame it on the game
like this why does this have the same
interface of the PSP man why are we
doing this that's what I'm talking about
this is why we mess with them please
agent great I mean they have some of the
best single-player games out right now
and I can't wait to uh you know one of
my buddies going on vacation I'm gonna
have to borrow his ps4 and like burn
through spider-man and God of War John
it for so but not another gaming podcast
the way we started it is so with three
hometown buddies all from Boston
obviously yeah three hometown buddies
you know we grew up roasting each other
and and you know just being you know
like-minded individuals we all play the
same stuff Chris and dr. Bob are more of
the PC side of the house so they do a
lot of Counter Strike they do a lot of
competitive games yeah Bob is the type
of person that like he'll pick something
up and he'll be like the best person I
know at the game with evoke you know
yeah he puts his money where his mouth
is man he I got to tell you like we have
like a running joke it's not even a joke
is it serious that I've never beaten Bob
in hearthstone I'm a big hearthstone guy
myself and I literally we were on our
way back from Dreamhack Montreal which
was a eSports competition they had
Starcraft hot stone csgo
they had smash tournaments you know the
whole thing and on the way back he had
never played hearthstone we watched a
finale then he goes man I'm gonna
download that as soon as we get back to
the hotel and then
he was whooping my ass up and down
hostel like 15 minutes later and I was
like oh my god I think now I got to hear
it from him so it was a bet to you
recently though he did was a bettin on a
screen I was like oh man what's going on
out here yeah so I don't even know how
the joke started Steve is in the chat
right now too and he's from he's a
regular for not into the gaming podcast
we love Steve and he has probably bore
witness to this I don't even know how
the joke got started about that we were
gonna sell his feet pictures on patreon
so so I don't know I I don't even know
how I started and we lost in a bet we
made a bet that episode 1 of the new
season a game of Thrones had a game
called rainbow bet yeah a gamble and I
said I would wear a t-shirt on stream
that said I have never beaten doctor Bob
in ha stone really lost which I didn't
and so he sat with his feet up just go
oh my god I was like like Dave King they
take off how about me on his back yeah
we would have you do in bet that's what
bend the knee kind of came from like the
evolution knows it we cleaned it up for
TV my cousin on the block but make it
that joint it's real it's really right
he's a man of the word so he was like
I'm all right and he took takes his
shoes off
and you just like and I was alright
we're gonna get like perma banned from
twitch and tos so you might as well just
take those take those puppies off the
screen yeah but ya know to keep it show
you know with three hometown buddies we
kind of grew up playing around along
with a lot of the same games you know
talking the same talk and we just kind
of came around one day and we're like
maybe we should start like a website
like let's just start let's just kind of
see what happens
my idea was the website and then Bob had
said to he's like man we should do a
podcast so we started the foundation
with the website back in 2016 and then
you know one to skip a few not another
gaming podcast now one of the top
trending gaming podcasts on spot
which is great I'm really happy about
that and you know we just it's just it's
a passion project and if it ever blows
up and we can get some gold-plated jet
skis and ride off into the sunset I'd be
pretty happy about that but other
otherwise it's just cool to like talk
about games with your boys once a week
and just something to do so absolutely
man yo much respect man hit it off with
you guys immediately without their packs
East and it was just kind of fun like
King says like seeing a reflection of
yourself that whole thing yeah outside
the yeah he was like I love the Nintendo
I didn't see which way he went I think
he had a beard I'm not sure no I mean I
actually we were we were watching it was
actually kind of a shame cuz the kid was
like minding his own business and then
randomly and somebody to his twitch this
was like 1080p 4k 60 frames per second
dude got clocked and left on the
sidewalk and I was like oh my god I hope
somehow he's okay yeah it was wild I
don't know the dude was like I think
they ended up they ended up catching up
to the guy and he got some retaliation
which was good cuz you can't be doing
that yeah but uh also know that we
weren't there to see that because I've
seen I've already seen like Rob get
aggressive before I don't want to see
somebody to rob is me yeah exactly we
were at a after-party for pax two years
ago and those
dude who was talking so much crap about
beer pong and there was beer pong at
this after party and he was like man I
don't lose you beer pong and then Rob
was like his eyes like his pupils of his
eyes like what like pinpricks like this
like he was like a cat's eyes and he was
like are you kidding me and then all of
a sudden dude came back and Rob smoked
their boots in beer pong and he was died
in the kid's face and he was like I
don't lose and I was asked why those two
that's literally king stuff right there
yep Joe he was today I swear like
normally he had to call me in the
morning
he had text me and it was a random
little text and I knew he thought he
wasn't gonna get a reaction brother I
was already showered in shame
hey you go see me man not another game
but yo tremendous man yo real quick we
got to do this before you for you get
you outta your personal segment is that
on we do it for all the guess what da
top five video games or franchises of
cool fashion oppression
I should have been ready man I should
have been ready for this okay no
particular order - cool so this is
probably the one that and if you guys
can if you guys appreciate this game
then I know that this is why this is how
we're like so cloned so Super Mario RPG
legend of the seven stars for Super
Nintendo I always keep a copy of it at
arm's life there's one literally right
over there buried in boxes but the Super
Nintendo is right there in case I even
need to blow the dust off and play it
yeah Super Mario RPG is my favorite of
all time
my first game that I ever beat like to
completion and I think I was probably
like I don't know 10 I'm not even like
it maybe eight or something like that
when I first beat it and I like was so
confused that it was over and I didn't
get that you could just be like man
yeah I think okay so Mario RPG Mass
Effect - OH
we talked about that actually did we
talk about because I that was when we
hugged because I was like man and soleus
like one time for more than I poured
some out from more dilute the pain
salute to the homies oh man I'm gonna
saw gettin choked up let's go oh so Mass
Effect 2
Mario RPG let's say I mean I have to
throw a Legend of Zelda game in there so
let's just say Zelda like in general
yeah like the whole franchise will just
throw the whole thing in there I could
say ocarina of time but I feel like
that's kind of cliche our thought is the
greatest oh my god they go have asked I
would know that game is trash I'll
happily go to the bushes if that's not
there so Zelda Zelda yeah that's three
let's see the fourth one I mean I have
to give it to I guess like I want to say
like Halo 2 or 3 I want to say like
maybe halo 3 I've had the most probably
like most online played time ever for
like Halo 2 or 3 and I think the fifth
one honestly is a NBA Jam tournament
edition samudaya get me in front of John
Stockton and calm alone yellow and they
had NBA Jam at PAX I don't know if you
guys were at the if you walked by the
the New Balance booth yes so I sat down
on the couch I was like real comfortable
and the guy was like all you do you play
or you know how to play NBA Jam and I
was like man take up their control oh
come on I was it way back Midway
Activision enacted well originally was
it was guest like now and then different
and then honorable mention World of
Warcraft's cuz I've been playing ones
with Warcraft for like all launch
yeah that's a go that's it ha ha T yes
my cut you know so I'm sorry no no I'm
new thinking I originally it was Midway
and then accordingly
he's never clean oh and uh here goes NBA
Jam Jam like they're not gonna get sued
sir we're final we can't oh but I'm only
gonna give you 25% of the screen got out
to events like yo-yos game Lodo's game
those a classics manioc tremendous five
man trying to like keep it yeah I'm like
every like every time I switch out like
four or five every time with like
something else also in like maybe we can
touch on this later because I know you
guys have an itinerary but I didn't know
you guys were big battle rap fans as
well and I happened to be as well so we
can touch on that if you want yeah yeah
he was talking Bob is necessary like he
is necessary wow really
man take him out take him out to eat
first never imagined Mortal Kombat when
you say really different but they're the
same exact person acts oh I'm a rep Bob
Dom Dom can you hear me
no he can't no I don't know what every
time I like refresh it it's a different
person that sounds muted so I have no
idea maybe one more time click click the
arrow button on sovereign yeah I'm you
know
now I haven't I like muted him before
and now I'm beautiful what no I'm you
know mute him see if I can't it says
muted it permanently I think know when I
was muted before that's crazy but a
little technical difficulty uh I'm using
it on I'm gonna try to like reopen
chrome Roku yes hold on it might be a
chrome as
well hold it nothing yeah no doubt
nice we gonna get all weather giant when
lord dom the legend comes back home last
week four results are in and the people
have spoken to the question with the
recent announcement reveal of the
initial piazza prospects by mark Cerny
which feature has you most excited about
the next generation PlayStation console
the winner at 42% in a fairly close
4-way ILP vote is the SSD fastest low
time group coming in that second at 27%
was backward compatibility for that
amazing ps4 library and a razor close
third place at 25% was you fraud in with
a km Oceano have number one if Greenwood
had a girl I know all you PlayStation
fans in his front and if you do got a a
4k you got the TCL chrome was to use
their software I think that's right
would it be so that was the end coming
up so at third place was the frauding
group 408 cables got I don't have 4k and
in last place at only 6 percent was the
ak4 that glorious PS 5 resolution group
salute all the 200 Lords that got into
the poll so uh Lord soft what do you
think about this certain you know like I
mean listen I have a few things to say
about especially with some Xbox leaks
and specifically pointing to the hard
drive that that is being talked about so
again I think the only thing in that PS
5 announcement that seemed feasible at
the moment that it's exciting is that
hard drive and how they choose to use
that just because again these games
getting bigger and bigger these worlds
getting bigger and bigger anything it's
just 2 gameplay faster I think is
fantastic especially if it's ingrained
into like the metal of the system and I
think Xbox is going the same route so I
think that's exciting because that's
something I think that's tangible
we can see immediately so we gonna get
into these topics so I start off a
little different because on solving an
addict have a combo kind of a topic in
my opinion so I want to combine y'all if
I want so solve we've got some suppose
some some scarlet stuff going on and
adequate rest leaks correct okay so I'm
gonna do it that way okay yes well let's
get this popping on solve you start off
and then we'll get add again as far as
what's going on okay so I'll start off
with um with our friend Club reals
Xbox scarlet leak so in in sort of light
of the PS five announcement by wired and
mark Cerny and what they talked about
and got people excited on the same day
that that uh which we call the xbox show
came out and talked about the SHA day
and just didn't sound great um so a
little bit after that Chlo brutal came
up and posted basically basically kind
of like a chart indicating some leaks
about stuff that we assumed about Xbox
garlotte and how Microsoft was gonna
approach launching into the next-gen so
what he did was posted sort of like uh
kind of like the it looked like a Lego
like a presentation type thing where he
didn't actually post it the document
that he got but what he did was take the
information from it including what was
blocked out and made like a chart to
made it make it sort of easy to see
fresh snow at the top the the Scarlet is
basically when you say Xbox Karla it's
talking about the two SKUs that
Microsoft is planning to use um into the
next-gen so you talk about Lockhart any
talks about anaconda so when they talk
about Lockhart they talk about this is
gonna be the value next-gen system the
model of the fixing the lowest price for
next-gen as they call it on the screen
no they're cool okay so they just like
the PlayStation they didn't talk about
specifics about the CPU or the GPU or
even the memory the only thing that they
did leave unblocked out was the fact
that they're using and a one terabyte
and DME SSD which is again pointing to
the same things that the PlayStation was
talking about in terms of speedy or low
times and things of that
nature doesn't say anything specific
about how it's gonna be utilized but
it's it's heartening to know that they
at least are going that route as well
now the interesting thing is that they
left unblocked is very Singh so the
rates are ray tracing is going to be
there in some way shape or form again as
we saw with the Xbox one X to the ps4
Pro that you know they gave us different
options for running things at different
resolutions different frame rates I just
see this as being an availing that's
available in the next-gen giving us even
another tier that we can decide to pick
all again ray tracing is very very
process intensive mm-hmm if it's not
built into the middle of the system and
it's just a software solution it's gonna
be very hard to get that running and
running well at a resolution that we're
accustomed to at this point I can very
easily see see it running at 30 frames
per second maybe a 720p or something
like that with all ray tracing effects
on and that would be pretty but it still
720p I just I need to address something
in the chat oh man let's go just I don't
really read you unless you put money up
imma read you right now Laura kognito
fan for all no that is not his name
sound like that means there's a whole
bunch of local fans out there but let me
tell you something he said I hate that
there will be two next-gen consoles Xbox
next gen consoles alright don't purchase
none of them
right it'll give you one school and you
did you gonna tell you how to do you did
I tell you how to spend your money
they're gonna dictate to you what's
right and you just go that way
so don't sit and say you don't want a
loop that me know if it's at least you
have a fan I I have someone with bunnies
I've sold I made a game
Twitter and they literally did you
signed his name is gaming addict and
everything so every time I see every
time I see him post on something I
always have that that gift that's like
the what give it it's like oh look at
this this is fraud Thanks over here we
ain't gonna do that in here man that man
she made the right choice in life we
gotta respect him he's on the right path
man I made it baby I made it I want to
talk about my guy and he's giving out
bad information
you gotta talk your troops
you gotta get high you spotlighted him
King that was your full complete
nonsense okay so that
backwards-compatibility another thing
that was there was blacked out so we
don't know details about that so for the
Anaconda is basically the same thing
just indicating that the nvme SSDs gonna
be in there ray tracing back compact
they also speak about the Dante which is
the dev kit codename and the interesting
thing about the dev kit is it usually
the dev kits considerably more powerful
than your top-of-the-line system
whatever whatever the actual hardware is
gonna be it's more powerful and they
indicated that it's the same exact specs
as the Anaconda so that's a little weird
to me yeah but at the same time kind of
heartening like really they didn't feel
like they had to make it more powerful
to the anacondas maybe that powerful
right um and then the wording in this in
this little uh in this this release also
is cool in it in that it it still has
you know the Anaconda as the undisputed
performance leader there's no wavering
in there so the marketing is one is the
best value the other one is the
performance the best value and again I
like I said the fact that Lockhart those
specs
that lockhart is going to be to me the
most important part of how they're
perceived in relation to sony starting
the next-gen i don't the anacondas gonna
be something else i think that lockhart
the bulk of people are looking at that
right
alright let's um let's get lord um and i
know time limits we got to get him as
much as possible yeah now with that
first rumor out between you know
obviously the word Lockhart and anaconda
specs any feelings either way about
these initial rumors yeah I think and uh
you know I'm wait actually waiting on
Chris P to get to my house so I mean I
know honestly I'm gonna just kick it for
as long as I possibly can and I do
respect the Kevin Durant burner accounts
in the chat man the Clippers never had a
chance warriors fan 35 I guess I mean I
guess honestly for me and like the buzz
words don't do anything for me like for
the PS 5 especially with ray-tracing 400
K 8,000 frames per second like that's
just a crock that's a that's a that's a
crock I honestly like I just want to see
how it plays like show me something real
show me something tangible you know I've
been a fan of X but like the whole Xbox
ecosystem for a very long time and
honestly the only thing that really
matters to me is gonna be how it feels
and how it plays like I don't I don't
really care cuz I mean if I have to go
out and buy a whole new TV I'm gonna be
more [ __ ] about that I'm gonna be real
mad but the I mean I've got a 4k TV in
my living room so hopefully that you
could just play it I don't want to have
to buy new tech like any other new
technology I just want to get a console
that feels great
whatever the definitive experience for
Halo Infinite is is the next console
that I am buying and you look at yeah if
you look exactly exactly I might have to
do that I got like you know I've got a
different financial situation than when
I did the last time I purchased a
console so but yeah I mean this to skews
I bought the hope the to skew situation
I do not mind that at all
let people pay for exactly what king was
saying like let people pay for what they
want and you know what if you want a
souped-up console if they gave you Xbox
1s an Xbox one X at launch
I'm sure it would be 5050 I probably
would have bought the S cuz my TV wasn't
like up to snuff and it wouldn't a kit I
wouldn't have cared the same thing when
they had like that Xbox 360 elite and
like basic packages you know if you want
to pay for the top tier storage and
whatever like that's totally fine but
yeah I mean whatever like who cares I
mean I think we're one step closer to
just everybody having a PC and they were
um you know and valve tried it they
thought that they would have had a the
answer to everything but it was so close
you almost had it but uh I think it's
exciting I think it's an exciting yeah I
think it's an exciting time to be in the
gaming sphere no matter where you are so
you know whether your entry level and
you're just kind of getting like Xbox
one or ps4 with your first console or
you've been playing hardcore games your
entire life and you just want something
new I just think you can't lose like the
fans are gonna win it's gonna be three
oh the fans and everything you know what
I mean so I'm really excited just to see
what comes next and hopefully you know
steel sharpens steel so hopefully with
the PS 5 X boxes hopefully they just
make a better experience for whoever
gold whatever brother man and the data
consumers win right result of that
competition so uh Lord addict man what
do you think about that those uh
anaconda scarlet lockhardt rumors that
we've heard so far man I don't care I
don't care about none of that he's our
resident tech specialist lordy he will
yo with frogs man frogs is like yo
because it doesn't look like that Mortal
Kombat on the switch I'm fine Oh
landlord King your feeling sir it was
the same thing as the PlayStation 5
information people looking for likes and
clicks and stuff so um it's nice that he
put that out there and you know I feel
that where the day and age where your
fanboy is gonna force you to do fanboy
things I thought that was a fanboy thing
we do the same way them leaking out that
fake information from CERN now when i'm
saying fake information and i'm not
saying that what he was saying was fake
I believe that's 100% factual in his
mind he didn't call salesman dude this
is the look this way and do something
else the way Seifer do and that's nice
it's cool that's his thing I just want
y'all to understand he didn't tell you
anything that you didn't know so at the
end of the day what was he giving you
the sleight-of-hand for what was it for
maybe it was for the information and all
that stuff was going on in xbox that day
remember they had their last of the year
of the Xbox of show and listen it was
just really weird and how it was time
that that information came out now on
the Xbox side it was like but let's
let's keep it real this is what we're
doing over here he put out his joint too
and was like but by the way I want you
to understand then no matter what you're
going to do you still will have less
power so it's just you know taking a
narrative away from you guys running
around with us on your chest he ripped
it off he put kryptonite in your pocket
that's it you don't gonna be fast but it
can't do nothing else all right so we
got I mean listen I'm I'm I'm kind of
which you can't get away like it's like
it's too early to be talking this kind
of stuff you know
I mean kobler's respected bomb I the
specs seem very similar so it's just
like I just want to see what the real
differentiators are between Lockhart and
then it's kind of based on that
it was like one his value on his thing
but it looks like a car because so much
is redacted like rocker is right next to
anaconda and I'm like this got to be the
difference and the other thing solve is
like the backward compatibility part
like is there gonna be differences in
backward am i right you wonder what why
is that blacked out it would be diff
listed on both systems some
differentiator it was it was absolutely
like like it was the petty response that
we were talking about last time like it
was just okay we doin apples for apples
oranges for oranges you guys have this
just making sure you know we have this
as well right and to me that's just what
it was it doesn't need to be anything
else but especially since we got no
numbers on CPU a GPU right yeah nothing
is talking points for nothing is legs
and clicks for nothing no no Lord addict
are we gonna get to are you talking
about here look at this crazy
all right my knees the Attic I had to
get my knees back CooCoo so you wanna go
down this list so what I want is is I
wanna yea or nay every time I say
something and you think it's credible
yay every time I say something you think
that ain't happening there is no way I
want I want in the bushes that's what I
want I want so much yeah you're already
bushes we're doing okay jeezum gears of
gears fog it's like Gears of War its
gears fine game what yay gears tactics
trailer
play dead new IP
bushes bushes yeah I'm gonna have to say
yay playdate wait let's get this right
played it is this play dead from limbo
in yes yeah oh yeah I actually yes yeah
quiet sister what's the low game that I
like the little psycho little boy game
well you do is I decide yes yes okay or
you know well of the West yeah yeah
that's pretty
2020 gamepads nay fraudulence which is I
don't know what is that I think that's
just saying the games coming out and
spring for game past I think though yeah
yeah yeah I think that's a yay
Battletoads 3 yay
brick yeah brick brick already came out
was it okay Rick reboot why did they
bring that back Donnell crisis yes yay
notice how we're almost in the middle of
this list that everyone thinks I don't
know let's say bushes yeah I saying he
showed nemesis before they show this
if they're even doing there's no Dommy
with it
what's the Dino Crisis you think it's
happening Dino Crisis happen yeah yes
yeah yeah yeah because that's all yes
and it said it's coming out this year
the base fable reboots pretty uh remakes
I guess they're gonna remake them all
for the Xbox one I would love that so
yeah aren't they all enhance now they're
all in the 360 imma go with the bushes
I'm gonna trailer yeah I'm Edie
I need a bushes or a yay I can't take it
I don't know you know we don't take IOU
in the realm bushes because and only
because they tried to reboot it already
they had fable legends and then I think
that got bushed for real right oh my for
muffled I thought you had it up to my
bed I'll put it back oh it's all you
know so Forza horizon 4 DLC I think this
isn't a bush that's happening though I
think it's happening
see these DLC yes the outer world
rewards coming out though this year it's
supposed to come out this year new
studio authorization yes a new rare IP
well you waiting edge that's the new
Ninja Theory game that's supposed to be
what it's cool that's the four player I
like that name though yeah yeah I would
say that yeah it's I think the samurai
aesthetic [ __ ] is like
right now so I definitely happened the
new rare IP will save me yeah I'm gonna
say bushes bushes
uh dead rise e5 that caught me off guard
I know didn't they killed dead rising oh
she did they said they killed it after
after four - I think I think it's in the
bushes - Dead Rising five I'm not dead
rising five record - trailer say yeah I
want it I would say yay only because I
think what's actually selling me on it
is that it's like game pass straight to
game pass I think I think we surprised
the reason I think it's coming out cuz
it's following the same path that or he
did you got its own definitive edition
and then they announced it like no like
you're not gonna you're not gonna give
something a definitive edition you have
no faith in the franchise when did it
come out when they repack them all it's
been a while like two because yeah has
it been two years yeah they could be
ready for a trailer yeah yeah it's a
trailer now your point 2077 yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah and this is [ __ ]
no CD Projekt RED is beyond the bushes
Age of Empires for I'm not saying I
think yet the yeah that's that's gonna
be too boring for a III reveal I think
they're gonna probably try to put pace
up the PC gaming halo halo no I said
splitter so yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like it okay good halo
infinite yay
yeah easy layer Xbox Scarlett T nay nay
yeah you say no how I don't use it done
uh I don't I don't know I just feel like
even though I mean when you think about
it I'm the Xbox one's been on for so
long I I don't think I'll say this I
will say nay conditionally if we
actually see a ps5
at e3 I think they whatever
well no if Sony because Sony's doing
their own thing they're doing their own
no no I haven't specifically said
they're doing anyone they said no they
said they're not doing anything that we
that's a lie they said they have no
plans for anything around e3 they can
have something in the chamber he's
objecting that they would do a YouTube
drop but as far as like a conference or
not a show they're not oh no nothing
like that
I know drop a Last of Us release date or
something like that like we talked about
before but yeah we're gonna get like a
Scorpio trail and where they say it's a
beast you best believe PlayStation 5
going to show a little skin you know and
I want you guys to realize and take in
that everyone agreed so over half the on
this list yo what about shot and voucher
for it I'm gonna tell you that I lost my
mean one time isn't too much on this
list it's just outlandish like it's just
not yeah that seems like a legit leak
why it does like there's a couple of
things on there that's that's ft but the
fact that one of the things that I saw
that I was like okay that that's weird
that I would see and that was the what's
that game that was see a CD Projekt RED
new IP like why would you put that on a
list yeah it could be something as small
as like a like a cell phone game that's
coming out with the actual game but it's
like why would you put that on a list
you know you know what though like think
about when they do it sounds far-fetched
but think about when they actually
announce CD a cyberpunk
yeah witcher 3 wasn't out yet mmm would
witcher 3 wasn't out yet when they when
they actually announced cyberpunk to be
working on it and showing a trailer
I mean but it again but it's in the
thing in the leak it says like a teaser
or some sort of teaser or something like
that Britney and that's what they did
that's what I'm saying it was it was a
trailer it was it was some CG thing I
forgot it was a there was a girl in it
and it just says cyberpunk 2077
cyberpunk beginning that it's not even
out at that point yet so it doesn't make
sense but they it's this precedent
though yeah I mean not I get I'm gonna
give it to you damn right after this I
think you seeing this list egg he's hurt
me because I look like this is low-key
conservative like it is sense that a lot
of things are kind of expected not
saying that they're all gonna happen at
the same time but majority of it for me
didn't feel out of the realm of
possibility outside of maybe two things
on my okay that's not happening but like
I was gonna even the stuff that we
confidence not gonna happen
I could see happening besides that
cyberpunk stuff I don't see that
happening at all was good well it's on
it man I think I mean this is the
Projekt RED thing is kind of throwing me
off I think if anything if absolutely
anything will get a kind of like a tease
like with star fields how we had from
Bethesda how it was just like a blank
screen and just star field and it was
like and that's all you get for now so
yeah JP I'm gonna get more than that
because they've already starting to show
giant portions of gameplay on these
games well no I mean for a cyberpunk
we'll see that but I think for the new
IPTS we might see maybe something I
don't know maybe we will but then again
CD Projekt RED strikes me as a type of
studio that leaves works on one thing at
once and I don't know I you're right
yeah I don't know they would want to why
they would want to detract from any of
the attention on I think whatever this
IP is it's gonna be related to cyberpunk
it's gonna be like a cell phone game
kind of like fallout shelter mm-hmm yo
day going into January this list is an L
the geeky nerd this les could be an L
your competition a you gotta go hard are
they going in on that I think that's
hard that list is true what else do you
that's like what three new IP
on that list once I entered I don't know
if I mean oh my first pull up can you
pull the list back up again no problem
you second let's put it like that is a
good list if everything on that comes
the true I would be happy with an e3 you
have that you'll be happy with eating
but I want a better listening that
anything but you can't say you can't be
the blades thank you like that studio
microphone Microsoft for just a quiet
show some game every last studio that's
what I would say if the Splinter Cell
reboot is an exclusive and Xbox
exclusive that would be a haymaker I
think that would be a I don't think
that'll happen I don't think it'll
happen
you guys got to think in one and one III
show you're going to get a fable
announcement if this is true and you're
gonna get the the ninja theory and a
week or two and you're gonna get all
leans towards you the Studios announced
a new IP and that's not to mention outer
Wars is probably the flannel game play
not gonna be a Megaton that's like a
this is literally one of the best list
that you could possibly have nice unlike
it ain't good but you gotta tell me what
you want you don't know what's going on
my socks off you don't know what's gonna
knock your socks off but you don't know
how do you know this would knock I don't
want this predictable listed Harley any
this is how it is you fable you can't
really you unless if I just fable just
plugging it stuff on you
I mean if you look at it from a
third-party standpoint you're having
Splinter Cell being put up on the
Fairlight yeah poor drift Tiger font
yeah
syrup on it that's great but you don't
care if another lousy shoulder baby over
here in this chat why don't you guys
tell me what it would make how is this a
safe lists no flight people say they
want you is is same they want new says
if it was true and there's three new
eyepiece coming out that's that's not
enough but I'm like that makes no
systems knocked off what can y'all so
anthem how it's not good enough I know
you sound like Tyrese right now what
more do you see a multiplex you guys
only focused on four or five there's
brand new ip's up there there's there's
sequels the games which you guys claim
you want sequels like that about it I
just don't get it just like you see
greatness when you see greatness you
play you know what it is between know
what it was gonna be like you couldn't
describe it until you soared so when
when it when they do what they supposed
to do on stage I was something out of
left field
I don't know but I know what I want it
to be too because Dalila wants to know
for real for real real I'm saying you
don't say cuz she's with you add like
widgets which I want to see like what
what about solve you wit it though right
like where's your feeling on this I'm I
think it's fine i mean there are new IP
there i see what king is coming from
he's like at this point with the one
thing they'd say
one thing the king said that I do agree
on is just because but again I don't
think it's feasible is every single new
acquisition shows what it won't be
possible there's pluses
I bet you initiative haven't even
started a game probably show you but I
think I think this list is fine if this
is true right and this list is fine and
if the council announcements at the end
of the at the end of the of the
conference blow your socks off I think
it's fine
there's no mic drop moments in our wacky
listen to me is gonna be the console
reveal showing hey right it could be
that way based on the investment that we
know Mike's office put it of course but
I'm looking at it from the standpoint if
we're looking at it I don't normally
address the truth okay the search should
show anything from each of the new
studios there is studios at the showi
I'm gonna tell you what digit theories
they just bought I guess they ain't
showing nothing from it it's not all let
me say well I'll give it to you some of
the King I think what it is is as gamers
we like to be surprised when you look at
this list physically on paper it
four-alarm predictable right the reality
is the footage and everything that could
be shown associated could be
mind-blowing yeah so we have to we have
to separate predictability based on what
we know versus what we see and what we
see could be great that's all I'm saying
so I know I feel that that's exactly
what I'm saying I'm late all right
that's a nice listen oh yeah I want that
left hook I want that smashmouth joint
that right
no bleeding edge isn't gonna be this I
don't know raise new eyes real quick
don't want to read that again Lowe's
podcast ask the panel how many people
how many new IDs would it take a key
scroll it up what it takes for the Xbox
we III fire or what the new IDs will
take is only cinematic narrative driven
IPS that are going to do it won't you
answer that king all right
so for me let me tell you something like
like I just told you I don't want that
left hook I want I want that you
deafblind right hand that you didn't see
I want them to step onstage I want that
mic drop moment remember when Phil we
all knew that cyberpunk was gonna show
up right mm-hm and I come from we had to
wait a week to get the VHS tape and then
we were blown away no no stop stop I got
to push you in the bushes all right this
is why this is why I don't like this I
don't like none of this I don't like
leaks coming out I don't like none of it
tighten up your [ __ ] right
[ __ ] button it up like Nintendo window
don't give you no list drop a little
trailer for for Metroid you like oh my
god like you feel it yes this this stuff
is ruining III ruining we get to addicts
portion of of that partner and I
completely agree now oh what a bleeding
edge is the most amazing sickening
what if Splinter Cell is a me oh my lord
eternal participate in the left hook can
you be shot okay let's take let's take
so that takes away I see what you say
you're saying that I think you wanna see
today he's saying he's saying no that if
the ending to endgame is it gonna be
better than going and watching the
ending game gay and I agree I should get
all off well I agree with you but at the
end of the day like you got last year
people said that they had a good III did
we all not sit here and say they had a
good III approach going and I think this
list blows that list out of the water
let me know
are we saying this isn't a good list
when everyone was okay off last year I
mean that wasn't okay with last year I
thought last year's e3 was coming
thought it was bronzed okay
and I'm the biggest like I mean I love
xbox and I'm probably gonna buy whatever
the new Xbox is anyway I'm gonna tell
you this right now uh gears 5im lukewarm
on Gibbs tactics I don't give a [ __ ]
about wait dad IP okay Ori man I mean I
don't I'm not like a huge indie game guy
so I guess keep shooting me I don't know
uh game pass stuff you gotta you know
they got to keep the lights on they're
gonna have to show this battle trouble
battletoads not gonna sell anything
borderlands 3 we're gonna see it every
conference brink I don't know who asked
for that Dino Crisis not gonna sell [ __ ]
Jedi fall in order we're gonna see and I
mean daddle crisis could be amazing but
it's not gonna sell Jedi fallen order is
we're gonna see in every conference I
can't wait to see it finished we're not
gonna see that every car every year
we're gonna see it like oh yeah yeah
yeah literally gonna be at this coffee
table cool can't wait a fabled reboot
I'm excited for that Forza I don't
really care about Cu things I don't
really care about outer worlds looks
great still don't know new studio
acquisitions I don't care if we don't
have a tease for a game if they say
we're gonna acquire a new studio and
guess what you have to follow that up
with a little like 1/2 of like and this
is what they're bringing to the table
because other than that seeing a Studios
logo on the screen doesn't mention any
it doesn't bleeding-edge could be the
best game ever anybody's ever made and
don't get me wrong I'm stoked for that I
think that's gonna be great so that'll
be probably a high point that'll be like
a shocking a little high point but it's
not gonna be shocking cuz we're reading
it new rare IP if it's not uh like a I
mean I'd be cool if it was I would like
a perfect dog reboot or something like
that it that would be kind of dope um
Dead Rising 5 Sambi zap laid out record
- I didn't play the first one so I don't
care
cyberpunk 2077 ok I guess like that that
was alright the dog dose I'm already
excited for it I've already
cited for it I'm already excited for it
I don't have to like this you need to go
sleep in the bush I'm talking I'm just
being realistic I'm not gonna I'm not
gonna be I mean I love Xbox and like I
said I'm going to I preface this and I'm
gonna sandwich it with I'm gonna buy
whatever I'm gonna buy the new Xbox
whatever it is you know I really hope
that we don't have to wait until the
very ends for the halo infinite stuff
split a cell reboot is probably gonna
blow people away but then it's like
available on all platforms so I don't
think that there's enough haymakers here
like what king was saying and I
completely 100 we need five or six
haymakers the knocker yeah you do ps4
head at six a makers last year what
the Gosselin's she what god of mode they
had god of war they had spider-man all
the world when I would lash it releases
like releases okay I got you I'm time
release is really sad I don't even
remember wasn't was last year the violin
year for uh yeah man the whole [ __ ] was
blown my god books that whole thing
retrospectively wait uh no I mean I
think like peas last year I think that
this is lukewarm I want to say I just I
just don't get how people could say it's
lukewarm but no one could tell me how to
make a fire like I just don't get that
like he said it's exactly what King said
is if we're not gonna know until we saw
it and it would be nice if like these
leaks didn't happen tighten the ship up
exactly what King was saying tighten the
ship up because if you mean to tell me
at the end of this conference if they if
they just said oh and by the way like
one more thing and then it's like that
little booth noise with the three lights
split us up
and then you get somebody from Ubisoft
walk onstage and they say it's gonna
come first to Xbox one the DLC is gonna
come first to Xbox one or something like
that I'd be mad
unless that game is an Xbox exclusive
I'd be mad and by the way and your
friends don't enter a conference with
another iPad no they didn't last it was
cyberpunk when everybody wait that it's
looking
why their expectations on the way that
it's looking that they're gonna if this
list is true that they're gonna into a
halo like I just don't get how you guys
are saying you really start with halo no
they're not artists with halos are
they're gonna start with because gears
is coming out this year what did they
start they start a low ashes
hey Lonnie with halo yeah they started
with halo yeah they had the halo is
gears really knocking anybody out of
their seats right now no no no kids it's
not knocking buddy out of this this is
just ridiculous like we cannot anybody
tears we can't open it like this is this
is crazy
and again like I'm an xbox guy this is
coming from an Xbox guy and I think that
this is gonna be good
but if there's no other but I think this
would be better if they knew that they
were actually gonna have more than one
press conference at e3 this year this is
the only press conference to see and I
think bright like the brink thing is
really throwing me for a loop get that
[ __ ] I love the fact that this is what
I'm talking about
y'all gotta understand this is not a bad
list right this is a great list is if
not a great list as a lukewarm list is a
nice list but when you have the only
show in town the new Ringling Brothers
you gots to bring that bang bang and I
don't see bang bang I'm not showing new
eye cream showing big third parties
showing DLC like I don't get how that
thought this isn't bang bang like I
don't I don't understand this is
anything people can do
brother Plato bills Microsoft announced
the list and all the multiplied suit
exclusive content for not water for one
year but forever so I guess he's talking
about like the old Call of Duty days
where they acknowledge like at the end
of the day like I just think you guys
like there's literally nothing Microsoft
can do to settle to happy people anymore
I'm confident now people ask for new IPs
they asked for taken away from like this
showing new hardware they're gonna show
you new IPs the showed you highly
anticipated third-party games show you
are those guys they're going to show you
a road meadows know that I good enough I
don't know what Hill is not you need you
better be better you gotta be better I'm
telling Microsoft right now you better
be better because you've been pissed
pause for a minute I want you to step it
up right now
and you better be better you're the only
one out there this week I'm going out
there I'm going to California by myself
for you so I want you to make sure that
you knock my subtle I'm gonna come back
on that plane with no socks firmly off
firmly off and I'm taking going into the
suitcase and I'm taking every pair of
socks in there and I'm throwing them out
the window too
this highly it take this is gonna go on
listen I just think the film needs to we
talked about this last week of the week
before like Phil needs to let go of that
that thought that beaten being afraid of
announcing something too early I think
you know he's been working hard on
getting the ship right making sure that
you know that the way they're
approaching the development of these
games doesn't put you in a position
where it's up in the air whether it's
you know games logging out or not what
they're working on something right they
show the same thing every year the
matter as long as it's coming out I just
think this is the opportunity if you
want to wow people right if III at the
point of III is just to wow people and
that's what it is and there you have the
stage to yourself I get that I say don't
be afraid
I don't care show me a game that's two
years out I want to see it I want to see
just because I and I said how do we not
no one wants to the ip's are two years
out like I don't get that like you guys
are acting like they're not showing
anything new like they're showing me
stuff that no I won't exactly what I
want the mic drop moments this is the
world series we add can we ask this and
I got a different attic can we we're
acting like none of this stuff on this
could have potential mic drop
Christine we haven't seen any of this
winning words absolutely and and I
understand what King is saying like just
based on the words that he's read and
its substance based on words or the
Penan going into this acting like these
new IP is going to be trash no that's
what you guys
if you're acting like there cannot be a
mic drop moment on this list you're
acting like it's gonna be meaty or cat
games that's what you're saying
go is what I'm gonna say and this is
kind of like a little bit both in
everybody's core because I his attic
does have a point with like you know if
the list is really this lukewarm then
what is it hold on it if the list is
that bad and you can't tell me what is
gonna make it better
then I think that's a more of an Xbox
problem than an Xbox fan problem because
and I'm gonna say this because I can't
immediately at the front of my mind
think of the last time I saw on III
staged an exclusive xbox only title that
was not a sequel that was a brand-new IP
that absolutely blew me away and said
this is the reason why if somebody asked
me at work tomorrow which console am i
buying good enough well we don't know
what they look like yet at it we don't
know what they look like
but we don't think that you can't
because you don't know there's also a
brink reboot on this list which could be
I'm gonna say this because I want this
to be good and I didn't even made that
day it was Bethesda it was about is
gonna be on my gravestone now that I
know that this exists I will say this is
that I really if every single game on
this list comes out with fire gameplay
footage we're gonna see halo infinite
gameplay we're gonna see Gears 5
gameplay which hopefully is just like
really like knock your socks off but
it's nothing we haven't seen before but
it's still good fable reboot give me
like a hot game play for fable and man
just like a like thinking of all of this
stuff and thinking about what could be
makes me really excited to be an Xbox
fan but and I want to say that and
that's this is a part of a symptom of a
larger problem the fact that
can't tell you addict we can't tell you
what would really knock our socks off
because we we just don't know what to
expect from xbox we expect he halo we
expect Gears we expect to see some good
third-party stuff we expect to see new
studio acquisitions all of this stuff is
pretty par for the course like I could
have made this list if you said if we
all said hey put 10 things on a list of
what you want to see from e3 I guarantee
all of us would have at least 7 out of
10 right and I get want them to I want
them I think we're all rooting for them
nobody on this show I don't think is
being like man Xbox is ass like they're
not gonna come with anything this is
this I'm switching sides condemn this
show because we keep out can we know
what to expect like all those two do ya
use the word lukewarm and me if you
think you're not condemning all of these
studio acquisitions that happen do you
really think that once they were
acquired by Microsoft they started
something brand new from scratch or they
were working on something already that's
probably kind of me their first game
coming out they already said that Ninja
Theory was working on a game before they
bought them I'm not alright one what
about the rest of them right so let's
say they did have stuff to in the
pipeline already that is gonna come out
as their first Microsoft exclusive so if
I doubt anybody let's say the initiative
right like you said initiative was
created specifically for this purpose if
they don't show anything cool I get that
obsidian besides outer worlds do you
think they won't work on anything else
like these these other smoke they
haven't even started it like haven't
even got we want to Metro this we want
to show a PNG at this point right Zeus
conclusive short-sighted to think that
they the moment they got picked
announced last year at last year's e3
that's when they started work on them
already in the middle of the development
or I don't let show me that
morning guys all right you're wanting to
wanted two of them like they picked up
Caesar you act like they picked up by
you are down for this list like know of
no but you're my you your mouth behind
it is
fire fire fire they spit hot fire no I
just talk to me no you guys can use
words like lukewarm when they literally
have to and everything we've been pretty
listen listen to me I want you I want
you yeah I just want you to understand
one thing if they go down this list and
they don't show nothing else but yo list
I will walk away with eat I will throw
their III strange dog off the roof and
into the bushes I would swear y'all do
not wanna know who I would be that's
Sunday on IOP this and they don't show
another game if they do this list and
I'm telling y'all now if y'all do this
list for addict 100 percent you know
what you like Cassady better come with
some verse it's not about that it's like
there's literally nothing in this
company at this point can do to satisfy
these people know like there's literally
nothing they can do no I think they were
injured the name so bad there's nothing
that can be done final but yet final
thoughts on this I swear to god I'll
leave it alone
so aside from aside from break which I
will not leave alone yes final thoughts
is first of all saying something's
lukewarm is not condemning it I can have
a bad slice of pizza at my favorite
pizza joint and be like damn alright
that was kind of weak but I'm not saying
tear the building down okay I'm not the
one are you gonna go back next week
finish let me finish only fish
this I will go back but if every single
one of these games has fire gameplay
that is phenomenal great that our
Microsoft is something that I can't
predict that I can't expect and I want
that new like I need this new and maybe
this new IP new rare I think there is it
hold on maybe this rare maybe it's on
this list and I don't see maybe it's on
the list and I don't see it yet and I
want the unexpected I want Xbox to kind
of subvert the expectations and it's not
just airs halo and whatever that we've
had Christine and halo for the last 20
III I want to be my socks throw my socks
at the end of the day is it Microsoft's
fault for not doing stuff on this list
or let's be ro we keep up with news way
more than the average consumer is there
that's the reason we can predict this
list
not everyone can Bridget the list like
people in this community cat now
everyone keeps up with every rumor and
everything that comes out like how is
that Microsoft fault that we keep our
ear to the floor and outside and we're
always are going to move on everyone got
no we would not agree on this topic
attic for the record I am with you King
Dom solved there on the other side and
that's just what it is you know look
they want their socks knocked off
they're not impressed
I get it don't know what Kanak their
socks off yeah in the bushes turn me if
you go back to the beginning of the
topic I was on your side and somehow I
managed to be so everybody so look we
gonna move on Mortal Kombat came out
Jesus and become I know it like I said
time you let me know if anything I know
I got you really but if you got you rock
it I'm not kidding yeah um well Mortal
Kombat came out so we got to talk about
obviously the legacy you know I'm saying
that's come out obviously and then it's
been a switch version and a lot of stuff
going on so on for the record did anyone
pick up mortal
at 11:00 and if they did any impressions
the Bujji PC versions they see on the PC
I could be by myself and I worry about
having CEO fraud no no I was never
reppin the switch version thank you very
much switch everything that fraud let
you know where you could put that floor
light right listen I gave up that battle
a long time ago you know when
Wolfenstein 2 came out like I'm good I
play from what I played I've only played
some of the like the training mode and
I've did a little bit the story more the
story mode is very cool I mean I have to
say that you know back in the day I used
to love all the story mode stuff in
Tekken um and then Mortal Kombat just
really elevated that to another level
after you know after 3 and once they
started doing that the different like
reboots with like um you know with the
weapon version of the fighter so and and
I forgot which was the first one that
really had this amazing story they it 9
like incorporate it incorporated like
everybody and you had all these
different sections where you had to play
with different characters um yeah they
really taken it to another level and
this does it yet again um I like the
fact that they are you know like Street
Fighter we go to Street Fighter you see
that's your your main characters they
age and and you know they they look
slightly different in newer iterations
but they still are them and the Mortal
Kombat seems very willing to just you
know move on from their characters in
some way shape or form right create some
sort of story thing how they come back
but at the end of the day they're very
willing to move forward from those
characters I'm loving it so far I think
the combat is as tight as it's ever been
I think the additions to the combat the
way that it's more up close now it makes
it feel a lot more very brutal like I
think it's as Brutus is brutal now as
it's ever been
the fatalities are nuts um the I forgot
the health they're called the moves that
look like fatalities but aren't fatal
role yes it'll blow there they they're
ridiculous but they're cool too
I'm liking it I don't once I finish the
story I'll have over a dick King Dom Dom
did you guys pick or did you pick up
motor combat or not really at your bag
from what I see on YouTube it looks fun
yeah I I haven't gotten around to
getting it just yet I did play it at PAX
East and I did get my hands on the
switch version um I did play it on ps4
and I played it on switch at PAX so I
got a little I got to spend a little
time with it um I mean it feels smooth
with honestly on the switch if somebody
was making jokes about like whether or
not it was a slide show or something
like that but it was smooth as hell and
when I played at the PAX East I I swear
to god it was I'm not lying I'm not even
like just trying to like sell a switch I
mean it was actually I was very
impressed with how smoothly it ran on
the graphics obviously were tuned down
which is like okay but honestly like the
gameplay itself I think they did
everything they could to make that thing
run and like a nice smooth 60 frames per
second which is what you need and I
think it looks good the story looks
amazing and there's a lot of stuff
floating around out there about like
microtransactions and everything which I
feel like is an easy buzzword to hop on
and say I don't choose to buy stuff yeah
they want to monetize their game that
they're selling for more money I don't
like it sorry that you can play the game
and unlock the stuff and you don't have
to buy it so I don't get what the
problem is and it's also not a pay2win
mechanic so I don't know Bush that whole
argument but um I don't know it looks I
mean it looks really good I'm gonna pick
it up I didn't rush out it wasn't like a
day one purchase for me because I've
been like dug in on the division 2 but
I'm very excited to get it and start
getting my ass whupped online it's gonna
be no Lord King let me tell you I'm
never left
I have Excel and I had the last one that
came out and I'm glad is in game pass
right now for free so if y'all can't
afford it go over the game no I want
cotton either
Oh 6660 daddy
holy hot they go dad Nintendo's the cpu
where they tried to do water for 20 feet
he paid for that switch tryna will run
red dead I swear you can put that on its
back and could listen exon I wanna I'm
gonna see the winning in this whole
thing is all switch owners because it
shows that the Unreal Engine is so
versatile that they can get the game
they can get the elbows listen I want
y'all to understand that when I was at
PAX and I'm telling you I haven't been
the greatest switch guy at atticus
fighting what is my um I haven't been
the greatest switch guy but I want y'all
to know the stuff that I saw at PAX was
insane right now I don't know what they
did I don't know what they unlocked I
don't know what went down but when I saw
the switch version of Mortal Kombat you
can rest assured that if you purchase if
you have only a switch and you want to
play Mortal Kombat on the go the game
looks phenomenal for the switch alright
um you didn't get a switch expecting it
to be Xbox 1x you didn't get a switch
expecting it to be a pro you got a
switch expecting it to be what it is
alright so we can we can stop beat and
switch up for being who they are they
are preaching the word I gotta show you
something alright I did my own analysis
of the Mortal Kombat so would you not
put my own diagram oh my you see this
okay understand
something right gotta be that everybody
purchase which was afraid you know you
know multi plant games hi
triple-a multiplayer games wasn't ever
going to make it onto the switch this
tells you date and day of release
remember we were joking that you know
come out years down the line it came out
date and date you know two of the big
consoles and it's on par in its hurry
area it's 60 frames per second I don't
care what nobody said at 60 frames per
second on that switch I don't care what
resolution it is you're playing at the
same speed and level of the big boys and
it it allows you to understand they have
mastered something in that switch and
I'm telling you y'all didn't see what
that sweet can really do because when
you get these couple of games that's
coming you wanna really use your switch
I'm waiting for these games to come out
so I can actually use my switch a little
bit more boy we did one team now once
the aim was tough they I was scared for
it because they wouldn't let us record
it
they were ninja stuff right King and I
walking over there and we're trying to
get it into you so we we stand on the
side right where they're playing Mortal
Kombat right so right there you they had
like two dudes watching anybody who
comes close to that Mortal Kombat chaos
especially if you're not online right so
we're there and King you know in a sly
way he picks up the GoPro and puts it
closer to his face and then he just has
it up there like and he just presses the
button the dude doesn't notice right so
the dude sees it and the media he's like
oh you guys are media yeah I'm you can
walk all the way to the other end of the
booth and ask if they can give you guys
some private time yes right over there
and we're like right over there yeah
right over there so we walk with nobody
over there they were just trying to get
us out yo shout-out to old boy who said
he's too big for me to tell some dishes
like he finesse the hell out of me and I
fell for the finesse that almost had I
was telling
it would have been one of those please
stop recording I the way they were going
about it it made me fearful for the game
after seeing the game boy I gotta give
it up I got a respected a 60 frames per
second I'm the graphics ain't too far
all shout out to digital foundry the
only thing is different is a resolution
and a couple of little graphical here in
is but the game is so close it's
sickening to let y'all understand like
it we get we got to stop we gotta cuz
there's no excuse anymore for these
multi planet developers there's no
excuse anymore for your game not to fit
on this slick there's no excuse anymore
for you not to include your version with
a switch version so it's down to the
developers now because that ball is in
your court because something this really
shouldn't be done and they doing it on a
scale that is impressive so I got a
period that I 8.0 update for the switch
they gave it the boost mode he got my
note book write this I literally say
y'all King I want you know what you see
I put my wizard cloak in the back I mean
listen switch gang stand up this is what
it is shout out to Shiva entertainment
man what sorcery you would NetherRealm
are doing on that switch Wow you know
I'm saying like it's it's pretty amazing
I mean I got a call yes the resolution
is lower we know that you don't I'm
saying we get the bad out the way but
the club and the close-ups with the
beards in the hair on certain people
look a little suspect la Crypt a little
que la but the actual gameplay the the
thing that you're doing the most the
core gameplay experience to consistent
60 frames per second even in portable
mode the minimal loading and like King
said that Unreal Engine man I've been to
me I don't know how they do it the
scalability with the fortnight
rocket League now Mortal Kombat and I'm
saying truly impressive
truly impressive and then the last thing
I'm saying is like you know with Unreal
Engine which is really amazing like
they're talking q3 2019 cross-play cross
progression coming you know I'm saying
that's what we want ultimately I don't
even know how they did this on the
switch but like King said other devs
y'all got y'all on notice y'all on
notice like Unreal Engine scalability
and what they're able to do with that
game and it's not that much of a drop
off your I have to salute which gang
stand up you gonna hear that slander
stitch you don't even ask the land imma
talk my talk
Mortal Kombat 11 coveted hot it's right
and wasn't Wolfenstein doom and you know
everything on there everything that
Bethesda has been doing with the switch
and they were the ones that paved the
way and they said listen man we're gonna
give you doom 2016 on the switch and
it's gonna run just as smooth as it does
on the console sure it's gonna be a
little ramp down a little bit and
somebody in the chat was like well why
does it have to be $60 though because
you can play it on the [ __ ] you can
play it on the plane bags
I was playing Skyrim on a plane on my
vacation last summer come on
that's what I'm talking we play if you
don't like that and if that's not for
you guess what don't wait on your [ __ ]
so like I said we go BT too much but I'd
pop my chest I do this almost out to
require you in this which gang yours L
ICU he said are we really loving this
for a bad but we coming in hot switch
about to surpass ps4 lights on sales
Japan as well so Louie go talk about
that MPD is talk to me Wow switch game
is our time to talk about you don't had
enough
I've been playing Final Fantasy seven on
the switch so I've been playing a switch
a lot coming around so look we move on
yeah like it's not even really about the
switch I just don't like Mortal Kombat
you know would you like the story any
story was yeah the story's good of
always like I just don't get along also
I got a shout out Ed Boon for being the
most approachable high triple a
multiplex to do know when I approached
them nobody was talking to him I went
over there and kick the whiffle ball I
was seething allocating for use King
King wants to see something graphically
amazing from Xbox Microsoft III but
praises switch graphics water-covered 11
I got to do that giveaway after King
Ranch because you didn't post no bread
alright is is the switch doing something
that we thought they couldn't do exactly
right now Microsoft is doing stuff that
we know they could do flex that muscle
bro you don't get no style points to
doing stuff that we know you can do I
don't care about your twist show me on
our backs uh me in a twist
show me some nice to switch jumping
through hoops making you look at your
switch like you turning it inside out
thinking little nose teaming your house
right but right now my saw you looking
at your xbox like bro you really
supposed to be blowing this pro out
you're really not doing it really expect
more so if you think I'm frauding but
expecting more for more powerful console
of course me $200 more it had that is
supposed to be the market leader in
power then show that power I'm seeing a
little switch over here the little
engine that could sticking his little
chess out talking about
much better than me bro from stage she
says I will get that 420 box of gay
passes and lobbyists it's coming around
get the holy spirit sir
get the Holy Spirit we got to do this
giveaway thing yes oh uh Lord cat daddy
fast acts he has sponsored a 3-month
Xbox Live code giveaway so how I'm gonna
do this I thought of a cool way to do
this this should be pretty relatively
easy I'm gonna give it to the first
person that puts in the chat with statue
King had in the background last week he
was good order that king of statues its
and let's see what it was he's
downstairs right now right that's a good
yeah what the statue is exactly where
that then and what NYC he got it hit me
up on Twitter yeah we got it we gotta
get wise we got to take care of NYT was
first - Chad - you still love will MIT
that's the guy that's that's the boy
right there
no no so yeah hit him up with the
information hit up Lord addict on
Twitter if not let us give us some
information we got to get that to you
you already know all addict I know you
got we got we we gotta wrap this up so
man no you gotta go darling and kept him
overtime crazy it's crazy I know we late
like crazy atomic um days go on we'll do
a quick thing the only person I believe
we can't do a quick thing all right okay
since we have to do this really fast
just give you a quick thought process on
what you see in the community and what
you if you
play to give your thought process on
that of what you think of days gone okay
unwarranted for what's going on with it
I'm gonna purchase the game I'm not
gonna do no fraud or you with it that's
not what they excel at they excel at
single person experiences in the dark in
the corner they also told you it will be
a day one patch that will go up with it
so I don't know if the day one patch
went out but I've noticed that this this
game was so beat down by Sony fans and
Xbox fans are like that y'all never gave
this game a chance anyway and y'all
looking for anything this is
confirmation bias on anybody's point at
this game
but it's good in this game real quick
I'm listen I'm probably the wrong / I am
biased like I clearly covered the game
at PAX East you know saying so shout out
the band shop bro your bias cuz the game
stuff would let you do that finesse at
this point is do you know is it still a
little edge the charities a great start
for being the finesse Kings at this
point though it's funny the chairs you
having fun so oh yeah pretty much like
you know look I played a shot the Ben
Studios shout out to my boy MJ the boss
wasn't even not next dizzy in a chat we
had put up the the three-part are cool
breaking down you know a whole aspects
of the mechanics of the game so look I
like it
I mean the crafting you know I'm saying
though the factions the rival gang stuff
the building to trust the story dialogue
praise to be little uneven certain
places you know saying I saw that
marriage seen almost cringe yo fam
really she's gonna say I want you to rob
me like that's awesome
like come on but you know I'm saying at
the end of the day you know some of the
question be a little repetitive extent
that artificially extending game but to
me what changed a game is that horde man
I just like that tension when they all
appointed him freakiest you know saying
Frankie's getting on you as crazy
it was say how you get to utilize them
against the other humans is really dope
to me and I want to shout out see now we
got Delilah to chat and we got on in
just quarter and I want to say about the
article that was inspired by those two
because my main point with this whole
thing is yes it may be a 7.5 game or
what have you and I'm saying but what I
like is the fact that what I'm hoping
for what seems to be the Sony trend is
say what you want about them ok
my what a game like this that may get
off a 7 in the beginning right equal
comes out and then they put in the money
for a sequel of a new and you guys
develop and it becomes some more you
gotta remember yeah I remember bend is
never this is the biggest game Bender's
ever made period period like you know
and they let it rock out forget that you
can have your opinion on something but
these are still made by a group of
individuals like you know they spent
years of their life on these games
that's all I'm saying
it's like at the end of the day I just
want oh hold on we got a Megaton a man
on for takeoff of showing a concern of
community love man I think I'm gonna
probably get this one of you right quick
- um yeah yo we got a big giveaway shot
- for tape man somebody about to get
some division - love it oh you don't
have to be crazy
well um yeah so I mean basically like
what's offset it's just one of them
things where it's like you know you hope
that they do enough it sells enough
because if it does most likely Saudis
gonna invest and keep them keep this IP
coming and nurture it you know I'm
saying and that's what I just want to
see from Xbox I you know at a time
sometimes I feel like if it ain't that
home run out the park King right like
they tend to walk away and I like
they're doing
the recourse equal I really like we call
always really nice and if that thing is
true in every call sequel then that
shows Microsoft is stepping in a
different direction and then moving
forward we called the VIPs like they
supposed to yeah your attic I just sent
it to you man we gotta do another
giveaway too for the people while we get
DOM and finish this off alright do you
want me doing that oh I have one do you
want to say it slow go ahead and be
doing the chat yeah yeah people know we
do at e3 shows no I want it you know we
obviously have two to three guys then
we're gonna have probably three to four
this year if you could guess two of them
the first one I guess two of them that's
gonna be at the show you get the code
now what not to that was who are mike
rizzo that our year if they can gets to
the ones that's going to be on this year
that's all well obviously not I should
know us they should notice if you
haven't watched it you not paying
attention all right so pretty much the
giveaway is guest yes to other people
that's gonna be on the guest be on our
Microsoft predictions show yes is she
that's that's what it is
okay okay based on ILP histories to get
okay Laurie to in the community also I
got a chance to win Division two all
right Johan Oh does he
oh it's close your eyes oh oh that was
very close he'll let go and that's the
one for the truth fine it's come on man
close you got you you got you got a
couple oh okay you guys forgetting a big
one no I think this is the whole team
yeah this you got the vision too so you
can't qualify even know why all right
all right quickly dizzy has won but we
didn't need to stop being in the shed
I'm dizzy got division too so if you got
different disease you got division to
you you county disqualified what
I'll be out to get another one just keep
going all right Cygnet working really
hard
dizzy came in messed it all up everybody
he should have been yo everybody should
go at dizzy dizzy that was a jerk I'll
let you make decision for foot just keep
keep going wild look through the
comments okay all right ohm so Dom broke
on Dom official guilty man I got this
boy so late no man it's all good I said
I'm waiting on Chris I'm like almost
ready to get my Sunday started bro yo
please dude you rather big absolutely oh
yes so as far as the you know today's
going situation what's offense are you
on with it I mean honestly so I haven't
played a whole lot of days gone outside
of the same same idea I mean I got got
some time some time to play it on at PAX
East and honestly like I'm not a hundred
percent like privy to all the
informations or all those stuff that's
going on when good days gone right now I
think there's gonna be a lot of people
that that'll be happy with what it is
it's a beautiful game you know I think
bikers and zombies and stuff like that
is a cool aesthetic and if you like that
stuff I think you're gonna have a great
time with it
part of me feels like that this boils
down to this argument boils down to let
people enjoy things and honestly for me
I think the aesthetic is cool I love Sam
Witwer Sam was an unbelievable voice
actor and I think that he's probably
does a great job in the main character
spot to me based on what I played if you
had blindfolded me and walked me into
the booth had me play the demo and then
said what do you think that game is
called I would have said I didn't know
that the last of us got my car DLC
it it looked like what was the one for
grand theft auto for the lost and the
damned like yeah I was like this is the
last of us the loss in the dam with it
isn't necessarily a bad thing right like
I mean it's a good game it's solid I
didn't I don't like the I think the
controls for me and I have a pretty
similar criticism with um the Last of Us
and like even like uncharted where I
feel like the movement is a little bit
too kind of like heavy and clunky you
know and then it works because of the
way that the game the cinematic area
like nature of the game but I don't love
that control style all these older yeah
I mean like that super tight to the
shoulder and it's like it's not as tight
as it should be on the sticks and
everything so I don't know I mean I'm
lukewarm on what I play it again I'm
gonna bring that game we're gonna bring
that word back lukewarm does not mean I
mean from what I played if I had to like
gun to my head like what I played was a
c-plus a seven out of ten and I'm sure
that people I'm sure there's some people
that love it and I'm sure there's some
people that hate it but I don't know I
mean I honestly am not super aware of
like what the Sony fans were promised
and like what they were supposed to
expect so I really don't know where some
of the followed is so you guys might be
able to like enlighten me on that but I
mean it's got a seven-point eight on
Metacritic for users and the 72 for a
meta school which just seems like a
pretty okay game some some glitches here
and there you know but again we got a C
post day one patch it's gonna work so
this morning the 1.05 patch came out and
it took a while to download again I when
I played I didn't see anything wrong
with it I didn't see any glitches I
don't really have any issues with it so
I had I can't really tell what the patch
is doing for it real definition equals
garbage after they don't want to
interrupt anyone know it hit me up on
Twitter I gotta go I'll send it to you
on the right ratio salute to the finest
man salute to dizzy patrolling the chat
is the busy hate took that got the best
of them for coming on thanks man yeah
even though you're wrong absolutely I'm
gonna let you hold out we can kick it at
that pizza shop with the lukewarm pizza
i'ma buy you a slice to me I gotta say
though the community man I guess that
same energy yeah hat you have for those
9.5 s and those tens it's not there and
then you know I'm not feeling that I'm
not feeling that yeah you don't come out
there and support when the sequel comes
out and it's a nine point five support
now right come out do go out there buy
that game because the game from what I
seen I get in the game is beautiful the
game has all the production value of a
triple-a game it just doesn't seem like
it's doing anything special to
differentiate it from some games of that
ilk that came before that's it okay you
know a quantum break quantum break and
it was in so I'm gonna I'm gonna play
through all of it I think I'm gonna
enjoy it when I played so far shout out
to the the section where I was murdering
little kid zombies that was in there our
kid freaker's that in there's no
question they're just kid freaking
you're dizzy so petty shouted is with
the father he tried to save someone from
that snorefest of division to wear them
great
I got to have some fun before I made my
feelings tonight with Gabe of my life
I'm gonna tell you right now this has
literally been the hardest week of my
life not just for you yeah we're going
to get the Sunday for Game of Thrones
and struggling and not listen to you
guys with this lemon I want to bust your
head with a hammer bro put out the
review talk about yo did you watch it
I wasn't right at all anyway he's
sitting there with his panels Cup
talking about all we gotta get into the
review I said I kindly shut you off sir
with the giveaway brother that was lit
lemarcus DDoS he was like yo I was
killing them kids too
that's all he was killing them kids to
see when you play you see yeah yeah I
won't you know shoutout to Microsoft and
discover for sending me my money so I
will be getting that game for the free D
and I will not have to do the finesse in
the back because I keep all you know so
many physical games because I don't
trust them oh yeah so sorry you got are
you good yeah yeah I mean I to me I
think it's you know it's gonna be it's a
fine game I think it's fine I'll finish
it and then I'll have a more detailed
assessment of it but I think it's fine I
think it's a lot of stuff is overblown
it's not you know world killing anything
like that but it's fine I want you to
understand um it's been reported that
Disney is getting ready to buy a massive
gaming studio now the studio is called
is a Korean PC mobile gaming company
called Exxon well Nexon un e x n and and
they're reportedly trying to purchase
them for thirteen point two billion this
is what this company is worth and I've
noticed that a lot of times like Disney
has taken back a lot of the IP
from gaming studios and not allowing
them to make like that x-men game or I
mean that the x-men game
The Avengers game like Thor game stuff
those games that they own the IPS - so
is this the step in the new direction
where they will be producing and making
their own games for mobile and hung
consoles alike with this new company and
for PC I thought what Dom no it's yeah I
mean so Nexon is really big with the
mobile games and stuff like that it's
like you guys are saying and you know I
mean they're worth like I mean I think
last year their net worth was like
quarter of a trillion dollars they had
like two to two hundred and fifty
billion or something like that which
they were worth which is and that's
again that's yet by the quarter of a
trillion yen I should I should clarify
let me map this out real quick two
hundred billion two hundred fifty three
billion yen in US dollars on this I'll
be like 75 huh oh now I can't even do
like these conversions not even make any
sense but but all of that it's uh that's
still pretty bits the only two billion
us it's like 2.2 billion u.s. which is
still nothing to sneeze at so that makes
sense that their acquisition would be
two points so they just buy them out
straight up for what they're worth I
don't know what this leads to but I
really don't want like a Star Wars
mobile you know free-to-play but you're
gonna buy everything like I want more
Triple A games from Disney and I don't
think this is what they need if they're
gonna buy out a studio you know let it
be like how much can they get I mean
what's the a going for these days you
know I mean like it or not it's not a
you know publisher but you know if
they're gonna buy somebody like spend
that 2.2 somewhere where your fans are
actually gonna get really quality games
there's no real early childhood games
anymore there's no real like kid games
except for the Lego series and stuff so
with all these licenses that you're
gobbling up why wouldn't you buy a
studio that's more tuned to make amazing
triple-a Disney games you know I mean
give me an
new aladdin platform or something my kid
you know and because that's a niche that
hasn't been felt that's that's not
something that's widely available if you
buy an xbox what's in what are three
games are you're gonna get for your kid
if your kids six or seven yeah
you know and they have a meet they can
eat they can make money hand over fist
with that and that would sell ice boxes
sell Playstations whatever I thought
that Disney quality games yeah quality
games and its quality pieces and I
thought that it was a I think it's weird
I mean I don't really love this move I
mean it's cool that they're like buying
up a studio but Nexon isn't exactly
known for like you know Triple A
blockbuster game or a known cash grab
microtransaction based game so and I
think that's what they're going for I
think it took to buy to buy this company
and then to then try to mold it into a
triple-a studio it's exactly the reason
they got out of doing that right they
didn't want that power anymore this
which is why they decided to they rather
just piecemeal their IP out to the
highest bidder and make sure you have a
triple-a team working on it that's why
you know they gave a spider-man over to
a to Sony and that's why the Avengers
game is being made by Square Enix so
it's I don't think that's what this is I
think this is that game that you know
that cut that company they could make
accompanying you know whatever games
they go with their big movie releases
and stuff like that and just make money
off of that I think this is this is what
they purchased in order to make cash
grab money off of their big IP when they
release big movies I think that's what
it is and I mean I think it's brilliant
but we're not getting anything beyond
that because it cuz it at that point you
would have to buy them and mold them
into a triple-a studio and that's not
what they are you can't make up
something they're not right I mean I'm
in agreement with cable especially a
dumb you know respect you to some extent
but I just got to see way more I think
they could take advantage of a bigger
things in our you know at the end of the
day you know I got to see them take on
the real Phil Phil luminous Harrison
Joe has started didn't impress me they
gotta take all scroll fills this has
definitely fell off there alright thank
you
we will have none at Stadio talk shout
out to my food UIL people this week with
all the recent leaks rumors and
speculation regarding the 2019 Microsoft
press conference which rumor do you
think most likely will come to pass the
choices are a X Box Lockhart prints
value and on Paul possibly with the PS 5
be new splinter cell game see another
studio acquisition or D I don't care
Xbox is in the bushes if they don't
announce with new IDs please write the
ILP vote when it goes up on Twitter
tomorrow Lord dark assed my brother
thank you for rockin out so long with us
an absolute pleasure to have you I feel
so guilty had your own but low-key I
don't cuz we got you longer that's fine
listen if anything Chris needs to feel
guilty because we're trying to get
oysters and martinis and stuff and I'm
trying to get out of here but he's
taking his sweet time so it's all good
it's absolute pleasure man where can I
find people find you what do you have
going on sir alright man so if you want
to keep up with us you can check us out
on twitch TV slash wicked good gaming
every Thursday every Thursday Eastern
Time 9 o'clock 9 p.m. live twitch.tv
slash wicked good gaming and listen if
keeping schedules is not your thing and
you want to just keep up with us after
the fact for the nice pre-recorded
episode if you like my voice now wait
till you hear that [ __ ] master
you can listen to us on any platform
podcast platform of choice Spotify
Google Play Apple music stitcher tune in
radio you know ChristianMingle
FarmersOnly any app on your phone it's
twitter.com slash wicked good games
Instagram it's wicked good gaming
everything everything everything and you
can find me at Uncle Doni on Twitter
uncle Tommy is at cuz I'm actually an
uncle I'm not like a father so poppadom
is a whole i could do a whole episode on
the origins of that name i am actually
you know that's the twitter handle so
check that out check us out is not
another gaming podcast and wicked good
gaming comm if you prefer the written
word and really really big shout out to
the lords man you guys have been an
unbelievable start to my sunday so thank
you so much for having me on man I
really appreciate thank you for coming
through this is this is a match made in
heaven we supposed that two great
podcasts linking up doing what we do put
every other podcast and the bushes say
that's my guy right there yo hopefully
but you have always better come out to
e3 if I don't know if we so this year I
mean with with me I mean Chris and dr.
Barbara in my wedding as well the two of
my groomsmen they're so I think III is
gonna be tough for us this year cuz my
wedding is like a couple weeks
afterwards so if I do that and then
don't have any money for the honeymoon
inside the doghouse inside the doghouse
inside the bush out there yo to shop the
attic everybody that came through chat
was absolutely lit Lord saw we can
define people find you what do you have
going on sir
first of all set out to Chris man when
we could good gaming I'm definitely yeah
I was outside on that line in the bushes
while you guys were happy but I will
stand in our lands on like not
sovereigns abroad I don't believe we
love said he will be fashionably late
good idea my crocodiles a matching go
my shoes I'm not leaving with you dude
you're jumping into El Camino and you
know how I Drive out and I was like
you're sovereign you need to leave when
we leave and he was like bro get out my
face I'm gonna be there when I'm around
Finley but I'm definitely looking
forward to your version of sob I have to
beat this DuBose definitely so you guys
you guys can find me on Twitter Lord
stop IOP being sovereign on PSN and Xbox
Live and just oh yeah of course and in
the inaugural episode of R & R with the
Lord's round table reviewed with the
Lords of cinema Lord Hogg the boss
myself Lord sovereign of course Lord Kai
Basu giving you all the endgame spoilers
in the dark for about five minutes then
working out the kinks you definitely
definitely Lake so take that just make
sure you've seen endgame already please
I don't want people cursing me out
saying you didn't say what spoilers
right at the top of it so please please
make sure you've seen any game already
and enjoy the rest of your Sunday guys
I'm about to get mentally ready to have
the night king destroy the rest of my
weekend so Lord King we're gonna find
people find what do you have going on
with the king of statutes stand what it
is let me pause Daniel's told you I got
a remote right you saw it right see him
turn him back around let Thanos turn
around and look you in the face of snap
your way alright let me tell you man
this week on Kos I got it let me pause
him right there right before he bought
this snap his fingers in your face eagle
alright so check this out this week on
KO west I got something going down
I got situations and I got another
situations I got circumstances and if we
did not see endgame I'm gonna give you a
crazy wicked spoiler
drop on your neck but I'm gonna tell you
if you thought my Thanos unveiled last
week was lit I was walking around my
house you know when you got a hot one
you know when you spit that hot burst
I was like wait didn't get a load of me
like it was so sick if you didn't go see
it please we'll see his last kinder stat
yeah
but this statue the statute is coming
right now
the statute us in that box right there
that dude right there yeah it's gonna
put it to shame Wow let's go quick that
statute is shame because this statue
weight when you go on three O'Day knows
no words no bars no no that's gonna be
hard to top listen listen trust me y'all
gonna find out some stuff this week like
you're gonna understand things this week
I like the format that I went with this
week I got a lot of positive responses
from you guys I loved it when y'all
leave comments leave comments if you see
something and you say something leave
comments because somebody told me I had
the music high too much or a week before
with the Hulk man statue I went back
down I lowered the volume I mixed it up
like he said yeah Chris said you like my
voice now I mixed it up nice and good so
he was able to hear and the beat was
fire everything's fine I had that but
this catching that's in this box because
this box I will be here next week
because that's actually gonna be
spinning them back you gonna love what's
in there now also we have Canelo vs.
Jacob on Cinco de Mayo and I'm going to
be in my bag I'm going to tell you
what's gonna happen
you can only watch it on the zone Oh
unless you got a streamer situation that
I don't know about we don't know we
don't we don't condone it but listen man
that's a fight that you want to see ya
ask for Canelo to step it up and start
fighting these challenges who can
actually push this boy to the brink and
I think that this is gonna be something
epic this is gonna be a footnote in our
boxing history that you're gonna let
cliff notes like I like like I like a
book up
mark a bookmark not a footnote a
bookmark in boxing history that you're
gonna go to and you're gonna remember
where you were that day when that
happened
absolutely you're king in a building
combat talk king of statutes all that
good stuff and you know arcade King will
be coming soon you know again I got said
can't thank you enough Lord on for
coming through absolute pleasure
thousand salutes to the laws man it was
always it was a pleasure pleasure being
in the round the chat was great you guys
were great so I'm happy to be here I
hope to return to the rel already know
that's a fact and like I said you
already know things like subscribe you
know the audio will be up by Lorde katsu
tonight SoundCloud Google Google Play
Spotify iTunes all that good stuff again
shout to my brother saw shout to Kai
again with round table reviews to our
and all our debut give us feedback just
like King said put in the comments
things we need to improve on things you
want to see you don't I'm saying it's
our first go around with it we're trying
to do something a little different again
from a spoiler cast perspective so you
haven't seen any game don't watch it but
exceed in game and you want to talk and
hear me complain you know they talk
about perfection a little bit and of
course a lot the last word woody boxes
that is up every Friday go check that
out for your looter shooter fix that
destiny to that division that anthem
that Borderlands coming soon please
check that out we got some special
guests to chat was legs again thank
y'all everybody for being amazing
everybody enjoy your Sunday
shut it tier because the night king is
coming and your favorites might be gone
but it is what it is that's what we do
in the realm everybody enjoy your Sunday
please